tapé sur la Star Ac voilà il a pas été
tendre
puisque la Nouvelle Star
Amazon
les gens et il a fait savoir qu'il avait
continué la musique après la Star
Academy de manière confidentielle
j'imagine est-ce qu'on considère pas
comme un chanteur mais un musicien et il
dit je ne veux pas écouter ce qui nous
aussi
surexposition c'est pas trop mon truc là
il y a des mecs qui ont fini qui nous
ont filmé et qui nous ont mis devant ils
nous ont matraqué à la télé dans toutes
les presses je crois j'ai fait 38 cours
de couverture pendant l'émission on t'a
imposé à l'antenne donc non je sais pas
le mien de buzz et alors pendant 21 ans
est-ce que tu as été très sollicitée par
des médias
de la téléréalité là enfin j'en ai eu
des propositions bien malsaines
et puis derrière il avait dit que
c'était truqué qu'à l'époque il avait
dit c'est je peux l'avouer tout était
truqué j'avais découvert que c'est moi
et Emma Daumas qui devions aller en
finale c'était décidé avant même
l'émission j'ai pété les plombs et les
produits mon élimination en demi-finale
car j'ai les menacé de tout balancer
c'était ça où on disait tout le problème
c'est que j'étais le plus vieux des
candidats et donc j'avais compris les
rouages moi
j'aimerais bien savoir c'est alors il y
a aussi une qui avait démenti tout ça
mais
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ça ce mec qui finalement a été connu
par cette émission qui m'a c'est comme
Olivia Ruiz quand on passe des images de
la Star Ac vous avez Jennifer et tout il
y en a une qui demande à être flouté
mais j'ai rien contre enfin Olivier à
son instarac tu serais peut-être épicé
aujourd'hui tu vois alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez euh Chantal ah non Sophie
quand même non mais là vous pouvez pas
non mais moi ça me choque parce que bon
alors c'était la Star Ac 2 donc
effectivement on avait peut-être pas
encore suffisamment connaissance de
l'ampleur du phénomène que on a quand
même vu à peu près avec Jennifer ce que
ça a donné il y a eu quand même une
espèce de vague incroyable de popularité
etc et puis voilà une espèce de
raz-de-marée où on a extrêmement mis en
avant elle était extrêmement médiatisée
donc je sais pas quoi il s'attendait en
fait ça attendait à quoi est-ce que
c'est pas devant la lumière mais tout et
puis surtout qu'à la base il n'est pas
chanteur c'est ce qu'il dit donc
qu'est-ce qu'il a les dans la
star s'il cherche ni l'exposition ni à
devenir chanteur non mais tu cherches
pas être exposé tu cherches pas à
devenir chanteur
énormément de casting sauvages on venait
te chercher et on te convaincre de
participer au jeu après moi je peux le
comprendre j'ai fait un gros télé
crochet Secret Story ça va faire bientôt
15 ans tous les ans les productions
m'appellent pour faire des reportages
gratos pour faire des interviews gratos
parce que tu leur appartiens à vie une
fois que tu l'as fait ma saison est en
train d'être rediffusée sur le câble
donc mon image est encore utilisé encore
utilisé moi je m'en fous j'ai adoré
faire l'âge je m'attendais pas déjà
j'avais 20 ans quand je l'ai fait tu
connais pas la télé
comme ça tu es des mots mais enfin bon
bref moi je m'en fous parce que j'ai
adoré faire l'expérience et j'adore en
parler maintenant genre Alain c'est vrai
que c'était pas le plus fort dans la
Star Academy tout le monde se moquait
lui tout le monde se foutait de lui donc
maintenant ça va faire 20 ans qu'on lui
ramasse la même chose il est juste
musicien dans son coin il veut qu'on lui
foute la paix terminé je comprends que
toi tu es pas choqué non plus tu
comprends aussi non je suis pas choqué
parce que parce que j'ai il y a pas
besoin d'être choqué par dessus
surtout ce que tout le monde dit tous
les anciens candidats disent depuis 20
ans et notamment la tricherie ou le côté
truqué on est là-bas qui n'arrête jamais
quoi tout le monde sait que la vérités
j'aime pas truqué j'aime bien qu'on dise
des stimuli
ou alors créer des choses pour qu'ils se
passent quelque chose tu crées des
choses mais tellement vrai on crée des
séquences pour voir tourner un talent
mais sinon il se passe rien Mathieu s'il
y a bien un programme dans lequel c'est
faux la triche c'est justement la Star
Ac de cette époque là parce que la star
n'a jamais voulu faire gagner un Cyril
Cinélu une Magali va et pourtant ils
sont allés au bout ils ont gagné donc ce
qu'il dit ça a été démenti et il y a
l'épreuve pour ce qu'il faut rappeler
aussi c'est à l'époque ils avaient pas
encore les contrats qu'ils négocier
après tout un candidat téléréalité donc
du coup ils ont tous un peu l'impression
de s'être fait flouer contrairement à
ceux qui ont suivi et c'est pour ça
notamment qu'il est l'un des seuls à
avoir refusé pour les 20 ans de la star
acara paraître et on le voit soit pas du
tout soit flouté sur les images des
pommes mais les contrats que tout savoir
moi ma petite star acade elle a fait
qu'un million à moi ma petite bon bah
moi grosse bombe la petite bombe c'était
ma petite bombe à moi sur le séjour sur
NRJ12 c'était pas Nicos le contrat que
j'ai signé je je cédais mon image pour
100 ans 100 ans ils peuvent la
rediffuser sur toutes les chaînes avec
ma gueule sur 100 ans je vous rassure ça
n'intéresse personne et je serais mort
avant mais il y a des contrats c'est ça
les contrats des juristes eh les
juristes c'est pour ça que le film peut
surprendre s'entendre aussi
mais en revanche je suis entièrement
d'accord avec Florian parce que si il
est l'accusation sur la triche était
super violente chez lui dans ce cas là
faut le prouver et sur le prouve pas ça
sert à rien de lancer une bombe comme ça
et dans tacher un programme il mérite
pas une telle indignité
juste une chose par rapport au sport aux
Jeux Olympiques par exemple je me
rappelle moi Nagano 98 j'arrive à
l'aéroport de comment de Narita et en
fait on me demande de signer une
décharge de mes droits pour toute la
durée des Jeux pour CBS et si je signe
pas ce truc là me donne pas mon
accréditation donc en fait c'est une
signature un peu forcé
d'Artagnan par exemple et moi quand j'ai
voulu réutiliser les images de
l'artagnan dans mon DVD ils m'ont
demandé 5000 balles la minute est-ce que
les droits vont appartenait moi par
exemple mes droits dans Secret Story
j'ai cédé mon image pour 1500 euros
c'est à dire que pendant 4 mois
simplement pendant la durée du programme
c'est à dire que toutes les couvertures
de magazines tout ce qui est utilisé
avec mon image c'était pour 1500 euros
et tout le reste c'était pour la prod je
m'en fous j'ai gagné j'ai je me suis dit
mais c'est pas si non alors juste pour
vous dire il y a une nouvelle saison de
la Star acade qui arrive je peux vous
donner un petit peu les dates ça sera
entre Noël et le réveillon
vous voyez ce que c'est descendre
réveillon c'est janvier
ça va durer 14 semaines
il y a une grosse rumeur
reviendrait dans la Star Ac voilà donc
cette fois-ci qui attend semaine mais
comment tu comment tu fais pour un
programme de 14 semaines entre le 25
décembre le 1er juin
[Applaudissements]
ce côté on est à la limite de
l'auxiliaire de vie ça va bébé smarthade
[Musique]